we have breaking news live from Turkey
the turkish President Recep Erdogan
speaking to members of parliament and
his security team president yuan saying
that in the wake of last week's failed
coup attempt that he is imposing a
three-month state of emergency again the
president of Turkey rage up Erwin saying
a three-month state of emergency will be
imposed this following that failed coup
attempt last week on Friday as you've no
doubt heard watching Bloomberg
Television thousands of people are
either being held in detention or those
are being asked to resign from their
positions those in academia as well
following this coup there is also news
today that US Secretary of State John
Kerry saying that the US would not be
extra dining a Muslim cleric a one who
is living here in the United States the
Turkish authorities have blamed him for
inciting that failed coup however
secretary Kerry's saying at this time
there is no proof there is no evidence
that the coup was led by mr. Gulen who
according to Turkish authorities led
that coup attempt of course we continue
to follow this story we'll bring you
more developments as soon as we get them